est ce que tu peux datés ou expliqué toi
ton peut-être a fait une erreur ou
peut-être des choses que tu aurais fait
aurait dû faire différemment va
peut-être pas eu non non je n'aurais pas
fait les choses différemment mais c'est
ma naïveté et le fait que j'étais pas je
sais pas c'est vraiment dans mon côté
personnel qui a foiré impasse que le
navire se fait-il que l'eau haddad n'ai
fait que des mots raison contre c'est un
papillon nuit non mais parce qu'on
attire les mauvaises rencontres dont on
essaie là moi je pense que tu devrais le
savoir doit par castaldi six nations et
nous le resterons donc oui stéphane
parce que vous avez une question oui je
n'avais pas d'amis autour d'elle a
beaucoup les amis personne c'est savoir
été souvent été abîmée mais c'est une
question par le choeur un mauvaise
rencontre
pendant 20 rapports avec les hommes et
je pense est important lorrain a
mentionné je pense maintenant c'est
l'amour qu'il faut oui mais parce que je
pense que pour vivre heureux
folamour seulement et est ce que tu en
es où
et je suis tout seul mais il faut
trouver un vrai amoureux qui est obligé
de trouver ce que tu dégages prépa pour
cette cette gentillesse que tu fais
vraiment vraiment être est ce que vous
pensez que parmi tous les hommes qui
sont venus vers vous beaucoup ne venait
que pour votre fortune ouvre popularité
votre gloire et pas pour ce que vous
êtes vraiment vous à 90 % oui c'est très
compliqué pour moi de
donc c'est quand il ya quelqu'un qui
s'approche de penser que l attend que
pour loana vous avez peur maintenant de
tout ce qui vous a pris j'ai très peur
de tout ce qui m'a frappé deux fois plus
méfiants car ben oui lâche est devenu
vraiment très méfiant avant que vous
rentriez quelqu'un va falloir vraiment
qu'il ya de votre confiance ne crois
rien c'est normal assez vend maintenant
c'est bon là maintenant il ya le fenêtre
écrire nous avons nous avons envie de
quoi la maintenon loana vous avez envie
je crois que vous occuper de vous
maintenant j'ai envie de m'occuper de ma
demeurant contre c'est vraiment à
d'abord et ensuite on verra
j'essaie de vous reconstruire de de
retrouver voilà celle que vous étiez
c'est ça pour me retrouver comme celle
que j'étais et puis ensuite je pense que
quand on commence à voir
elle sur le chemin du bonheur en titre
le bo nice tout seul sur y est capable
vous avez en vidéo lots d'euros fonder
une famille de repartir avec quelqu'un
de à oui oui je rêve de rencontrer
quelqu'un d'autre on a une famille à sa
cession c'est la finalité est de ma vie